The initial generation of the primary genetic
sequence of a particular organism is called
de novo sequencing.
A detailed genetic analysis of any organism
is possible only after de novo sequencing
has been performed.
De novo sequencing is typically accomplished
by assembling individual sequence reads into
longer contiguous sequences or correctly ordered
contigs in the absence of a reference sequence.
Historically, de novo sequencing was carried
out using capillary electrophoresis sequencers.
With its long-read lengths and high accuracy,
CE-based sequencing made overlap consensus
assembly the gold-standard technology for
de novo projects.
However, more recently, the high-throughput
capabilities of massively parallel sequencing
and the development of short-read assemblers
have significantly reduced the time and cost
associated with sequencing an entire genome.
During the de novo assembly process, partially
or sometimes fully overlapping reads are assembled
into one or more contigs.
Sets of overlapping or non-overlapping contigs
are joined into one or more scaffolds.
Sets of overlapping or non-overlapping scaffolds
are joined into a single chromosome.
In the contig assembly step, reads must overlap
by a minimum number of base pairs, or k-mers,
before they can be mapped together.
In the scaffold assembly step, contigs do
not necessarily have to overlap in order to
be joined together.
This can be attributed to paired-end sequencing.
In the chromosome assembly step, scaffolds
are joined together in a gap-filling, gap-closing,
or genome finishing process.
This final step is difficult and sometimes
impossible to complete using only short-read
technology.
The presence of repetitive sequences especially
can inhibit gap-filling using only short-reads,
although some progress is being made in this
area.
Finishing complete chromosomes often require
the use of multiple sequencing technologies
and hybrid assembly protocols.
It is common to see short-read technology
combined with long-read technology to generate
fully finished genomes.
Employing multiple sequencing technologies
on a per-sample basis can be costly.
There are many de novo assembly algorithms
and software applications available for Next
Generation sequencing projects.
For small genome assembly such as bacterial
scale genomes, tools such as Spades and Geneious
can be useful.
The major factors that determine the required
depth in a de novo genome sequencing study
are the error rate of the sequencing method,
the assembly algorithms used, the repeat complexity
of the particular genome under study and the
read length.
Genomes that have been sequenced to high depths
by short-read technologies are not necessarily
a substantial improvement in assembly quality
compared with those produced using the earlier
lower-coverage Sanger sequencing technology.
Although the human genome was initially assembled
to high quality with 8–10-fold coverage
using long-read Sanger sequencing, a raw coverage
of approximately 73-fold was required to generate
the first short-read-only assembly of the
giant panda genome that was of lower quality
than the human genome.
A similarly low coverage, approximately 7.5-fold
dog genome, which is similar in size to that
of the giant panda and was assembled using
Sanger sequencing reads, is more complete
and more contiguous than the giant panda genome.
These differences arise because Sanger sequencing
reads are longer, are derived from larger
insert libraries and can be assembled using
mature assembly algorithms.
High-quality assemblies are now often produced
using hybrid approaches, in which the advantages
of high-depth, short-read sequencing are complemented
with those of lower-depth but longer-read
sequencing.
In general, low coverage has two principal
effects on analyses and biological interpretation.
First, it is not possible to resolve whether
an absence of a protein-coding gene, or a
disruption of its open reading frame, represents
a deficiency of the assembly or a real evolutionary
gene loss.
Second, and perhaps more seriously, low depth
can introduce sequence errors that are in
danger of being mistakenly propagated through
downstream analyses and misdirecting conclusions
of a study.
To mitigate this possibility, two approaches
are recommended.
First, low-quality bases or sequences that
align poorly against a closely related genome
should be discarded from such analyses.
Second, adjacent bases that have high-quality
scores should also be discarded because they
can contain a high density of residual sequence
errors.